les infirmières libérales sont en colère
manque de reconnaissance baisses de
tarifs des actes médicaux
depuis les années 70 les revendications
des infirmiers libéraux n'ont pas changé
en 1971
cette infirmière dénonçait le manque de
considération du ministère du travail
qui leur refusait un statut fiscal
au début une infirmière libérale était
simplement une femme qui faisait des
piqûres et bien que tout ceci et évoluer
les pouvoirs publics par s considéré
encore comme tel les infirmiers libéraux
comme d'autres professions de santé
permette le maintien des patients à
domicile plutôt que des séjours à
l'hôpital
en 1985 cette infirmière en grève
rappeler cette réalité et réclamait avec
plusieurs de ses collègues une
revalorisation des honoraires ou
actuellement 12 francs 70
voilà l'ennemi c'est l'acte moyens c'est
la lettre l'intramusculaire l'acte
moyens infirmiers tous est insuffisant
pour vous prouver c'est insuffisant
parce que si on veut faire du travail
correct bien s'occuper du malade on ne
peut pas il faut faire beaucoup d'actes
à ce moment alors faire la course à
lattes une course à l'acte contraire aux
valeurs de son métier c'est quoi le
travail infirmier alors c'est non
seulement faire la piqûre mais cette
offre s'avère réussie du travail du
médico social c'est aussi quelquefois
rendre service aux gens les emmener à
racine radiologue sa demande du temps ça
demande du temps les réformes de santé
se succèdent mais les infirmiers
libéraux ne se sont toujours pas prises
en compte
exemple en 2000 l'ogc encan de brume et
même une petite échauffourée avec les
forces de l'ordre
les infirmières libérales voulait cet
après-midi faire entendre leur
opposition au psi le projet de soins
infirmiers
cette réforme prévoyait notamment que
les soins d'hygiène des patients ne soit
plus effectué par des infirmiers mais
par des auxiliaires de vie non
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
un nouveau coup dur pour la profession
on dit que la toilette c'est un outil un
fermier c'est un outil de surveillance
clinique hélène limât demi cible que
dans un pays où on prône la prévention
ont plus exclure les personnes âgées les
personnes handicapées du système de
soins en 2007 la revalorisation des
tarifs revient au coeur des
revendications
les tarifs n'ont pas bougé depuis 1984
quand j'ai commencé à travailler il y
avait un tarif pour le dimanche et les
jours fériés
aujourd'hui en 2007 les tarifs ont pas
bougé 24 ans en augmentation aujourd'hui
la mobilisation des infirmiers libéraux
n'a pas faibli fin 2018 il disait être
les grands oubliés du plan santé du
gouvernement
le malaise persiste dans la profession
un malaise qui dure depuis 50 ans
[Musique]